this is the moment officers from
Russia's domestic intelligence agency
the FSB came for Yvonne safronov on his
way to his new job at Russia's space
agency Roscosmos many years a defense
correspondent he's accused of treason
allegedly passing state secrets back in
2017 to check intelligence about Russian
arms deals a charge he says he's not
guilty of journalist colleagues who came
out to protest his arrest in Moscow
detained one by one Yelena Channing Kerr
had worked with him for years he would
never commit treason
sell state secrets to another country
especially to a NATO country he is a
patriot last week was a bad week for
journalists svetlana prokofyeva found
guilty on Monday of justifying terrorism
for writing an editorial in which she
said the Kremlin's crackdown on
political dissent might have led a
teenage suicide bomber to target a
regional FSB office though she was let
off jail time she has to pay instead a
five and a half thousand pound fine
Andrei solder Taub who has written a
number of books on the workings of
Russia's Secret Service says it signals
a new level of repression against
journalists this guy wants a throne of
he spent his life in journalism ten
years covering the Milton industrial
complex and arm sales Vera says the
thing for Putin personally and for the
Kremlin and now we got this message but
now it's soft literacy you cannot do
that so you cannot cover these things
you cannot write about these things
anymore because the FSB will stop you
Big Brother is still watching obviously
the levels of state repression now are
entirely different to how they were in
Soviet times but what has become
increasingly clear over the 20 years
that President Putin has been in power
is the extent to which the man in that
building have come to control the entire
apparatus of the state and everything
that had
in Russia as a defense correspondent
safronov had followed in his father's
footsteps
in 2007 yvonne saffron of senior had
mysteriously fallen from a window just
as he was about to publish an
investigation into the sale of
prohibited weapons by russia to iran via
belarus lost some of the detention of
another journalist even Golan off on
bogus drugs charges sparked large
protests the police eventually dropped
the charges the FSB is a very different
entity and once it's locked onto its
targets it does not tend to let them go
the trial will be held behind closed
doors that means the public will have to
take the courts word for it on whether
safronov did betray state secrets or
just acted as any journalist would
dynamic nice sky news Moscow